[Music]
on this friday night
more dark days on deck the newest covet
19 projections
hold tight and don't give up what
canada's top
doctor is calling for to crush the curve
tragedy strikes at a construction site
the trapped workers and panicked moments
brexit deal deadlock as the deadline
creeps closer it's a difficult situation
the sticking points and the fears plus
collecting is contagious my mom gave
away
all my hockey cards the pandemic fuels
memorabilia
global popularity with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
there's a dire new warning tonight about
where covid 19 is headed in canada
new modeling suggests the virus is
surging just about everywhere
and there's an urgent need to bend the
curve an increase in community spread is
leading to more
and larger outbreaks health officials
predict by christmas canada could see a
total of 577
000 cases and close to 15 000 deaths
the country is on a rapid growth
trajectory
if we maintain our current number of
contacts the epidemic will resurge
if we reduce our contacts to only
essential activities
we could get the virus under control
there is no other way we must
reduce our in-person contacts
right now a vaccine in a week
or in a month won't help you if you get
coveted 19
today so our message to canadians
is simple hold tight and don't give up
as david aiken reports health officials
say without more stringent measures
canadians will have a tough time
stopping the spread
covert 19 is still presenting a very
clear danger to canadians all across the
country
on the eve of the first covet 19
vaccines arriving in canada
a reality check about the current covet
19 crisis
folks the situation is still very very
serious
we're still battling the second wave
canada is seeing about 6 500
new coven 19 cases a day
hospitals in many parts of the country
cannot keep up
and on friday a new warning that that
daily case count
could climb past 12 000 by january
there's little indication this upward
trajectory will change without further
intensifying public health measures
the main problem the six provinces west
of atlantic canada
and while measures taken two weeks ago
in bc and manitoba
are starting to have an effect more may
have to be done
in all provinces knowing access to safe
and effective vaccines for all canadians
is within sight
might lead some to think over 19 is no
longer a problem
but the reality is very different
ontario got the message on friday
it announced new lockdowns and tighter
restrictions
for several regions in the province as
we begin to roll out vaccines
we can't take anything for granted
please
keep up the fight make sure we social
distance
wear a mask wash your hands ontario also
sketched out its
vaccine rollout plan a rollout that will
be quarterbacked by rick hillier
canada's former chief of defense staff
and will begin at hospitals in toronto
and ottawa what we're starting with
is moving those health care workers and
the workers and the essential visitors
from those long-term care homes
to the vaccination sites and as one of
the doctors said to me by doing that
alone
will improve the protection of the
residents in that long-term care owned
by 90 plus percent
because the coven 19 enters the home
through those people but getting the
pfizer biontech vaccine in place over
the weekend
will be a massive and complex logistical
operation
one that federal provincial and
healthcare partners practiced
during a dry run on friday david aiken
global news
ottawa residents of a long-term care
center in montreal will be among the
first in quebec to get the covet 19
vaccine
people at memonides geriatrics center
have been told to prepare for the shot
as early as tonight
immunizations were originally scheduled
for next week
family representatives have been sent
consent forms and background information
the facility has had two serious
outbreaks of covet 19
15 people have died in the u.s the food
and drug administration is facing major
pressure to approve the pfizer biontech
vaccine
there are reports the fda's chief could
be out of a job
if it's not approved by the end of the
day the vaccine was endorsed thursday as
safe and effective by an independent
panel of experts
now it's up to the fda to sign off and
get it to the public
america's one day death toll reached a
new high overnight with more than 3 100
people
dying from the virus jennifer johnson
reports on the growing desperation to
get the pandemic
under control the u.s food and drug
administration is promising anxious
americans it will act
quickly in giving final approval to the
country's first
covet 19 vaccine the department of
health says inoculations will begin
monday or tuesday
as the country breaks daily records for
new cases and deaths
we are in the time frame now that
probably for the next 60 to 90 days
we're going to have more desperate day
than we had in 911 where we had at pearl
harbor
ups and fedex trucks and planes under
protection of u.s marshals
will deliver millions of doses from
pfizer's freezer farm
in michigan to hospitals and pharmacies
across the country
now stocked with their own ultra cold
freezers the logistics here are going to
be
complex but but we're really excited
the trump administration's operation
warp speed plans to have
25 million americans vaccinated by the
end of december
a race against time for those on the
front lines having the vaccine
for us is just the beginning to the end
of this pandemic
healthcare workers and nursing home
residents will be vaccinated first
americans over 65 and those with serious
pre-existing health conditions will
follow
meanwhile the fda will discuss approval
of the moderna vaccine next week
if that's approved millions more could
be vaccinated in january and february
federal health officials are encouraging
americans to trust
these shots the speed with which it's
been done
does not compromise safety
health officials are urging everyone to
get vaccinated as soon as they can
the country needs 70 percent of the
population inoculated to achieve
herd immunity to finally get this
pandemic
under control jennifer johnson global
news
washington ontario is tightening
restrictions to help slow the spread of
the virus
starting monday windsor essex and york
region will be locked down for at least
28 days
five other regions will see tougher
measures too the province says the
measures will help protect
hospital capacity and ensure schools
stay open
toronto and peel region are staying in
lockdown
there's an alarming spike in outbreaks
in indigenous communities across the
country
as of yesterday there have been more
than 5 000 confirmed cases
on first nations reserves since the
pandemic began
there are currently 2 100 active cases
of coven 19.
the chief medical officer of public
health for indigenous services
canada says the rising numbers are
concerning
it is distressing that the number of
active cases
has doubled in the past month and the
current number
of active cases is over 20 times
higher than the peak number during the
first wave of the pandemic
for first nations on reserve
there's a bit of a silver lining to the
pandemic new calculations show the
world's greenhouse gas emissions drop
substantially
in 2020. the global carbon project says
34 billion metric tons have been put
into the air
this year that's nearly two and a half
billion less than in 2019
it works out to a seven percent drop the
biggest ever recorded
scientists say the reduction is mainly
because people are staying home
traveling less by car and plane
emissions are expected to jump back
up after the pandemic there's no vaccine
to protect the world from pollution
that's why the canadian government is
unveiling new measures
aimed at reducing our country's
greenhouse gas emissions
eric sorensen has more on the new
climate change commitments
and the potential impact on taxpayers
on a december day about five degrees
warmer than average in southern ontario
the prime minister announced a 15
billion dollar plan to slow down global
warming
and exceed all previous commitments to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions
the big item the price on carbon will
keep climbing on top of the current plan
of 50
a ton by 2022 an additional 15
a year to 170 dollars a ton by 2030
at the gas pump alone it will add more
than 27 cents a liter over those eight
years
the revenue will be turned into rebates
for taxpayers but the aim is clear
to push canadians and businesses off
fossil fuels
and the message to businesses to
investors to canadians into the world
that canada is serious not just about
fighting climate change
but about the tremendous economic
opportunities
that will come with moving towards a
cleaner future
the prime minister is counting on the
supreme court to turn back challenges
from some conservative-led provinces
ontario's premier says higher fuel
prices will make the country
uncompetitive
i'm a strong believer of protecting the
environment
but you don't have to protect the
environment on the backs
of the hard-working people of this
province in this
country have never ever ever been more
disappointed in announcement
ever ottawa will also invest in cleaner
transportation
electric vehicles and infrastructure it
will spur canadians to make their homes
energy efficient
and spend millions to help heavy
industry reduce their emissions
the plan comes one day before the fifth
anniversary of the paris climate
agreement
under that agreement ottawa promised to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions by 30
percent below
2005 levels by the year 2030 but canada
was only on track to come in
19 below the new plan now aims for
32 percent and as much as 40 if
provinces get
on board governments across the country
are going to have to put a lot more
money on the table to get the transfer
transformative action that we need
canadians need to start seeing
themselves and their communities
as prospering from that clean economy
more global investors are shifting to a
green economy
and this country says the prime minister
must get ahead
or will fall behind eric sorensen global
news
toronto european leaders have also
agreed to tougher 2030 climate goals
the european union's 27 member states
have approved a plan to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions
by at least 55 percent by 2030. that's
up from the current 40
target the eu hopes the tougher measures
will help it reach
climate neutrality by 2050.
a partial collapse at a building under
construction coming up the deadly day at
an ontario work site
plus the battle for a brexit deal
one person is dead and several others
are injured after a building under
construction
partially collapsed in london ontario
city officials say crews were working on
site when a four-story wall collapsed
dropping some people inside multiple
people were rushed to hospital
two are reportedly in serious condition
brexit trade talks appear to be going
nowhere in just three weeks
the uk's transition period out of the
european union
ends without a deal businesses across
britain will be in
uncharted waters more than 40 percent of
british exporters
enter the eu without tariffs but as
crystal gomez reports
that could all change in the new year
one year ago with dramatic flair
british prime minister boris johnson
pledged to get brexit done
breaking into the european union's
single market as an
outsider however isn't proving to be as
easy as
busting a styrofoam wall we have
repeatedly
made clear to our uk partners that the
principle of
fair competition is a preconditioned
to privileged access to the eu market
it is the largest single market in the
world
three walls stand in the path of a deal
fishing rights is number one
the eu wants continued access to uk
waters
britain argues locals should have
priority
then there's the eu's demand for a level
playing field saying
unity is needed on issues such as labor
standards and environmental protections
britain says it should have freedom
going forward
which could lead to enhanced national
regulations
lastly dispute resolution britain says
it should no longer be
governed by the european court of
justice 12 months later at a different
plant tour
johnson is changing tactics there are
opportunities for
companies in this country to think even
more globally
than they currently do and at the moment
people have been very confined to
their eye they're keeping their ideas
very much confined to the to the
european market and they they might want
to be
much more global the 27 eu nation
leaders were briefed thursday
on the state of negotiations and told
talks could end
sunday we are preparing for the worst
hoping for the best
and now it seems it seems difficult it's
a difficult situation
if the year ends without a deal goods
may no longer
smoothly move across borders there are
fears of food shortages new taxes
and undue pressure on an already
depressed economy
crystal commansing global news london
still ahead the trauma in nova scotia
after april's mass killing
rcmp in nova scotia are asking for the
public's help
identifying people who may have been
involved in vandalizing two facilities
where mikmaw fishermen stored their
lobster catch 21 people have been
arrested
and surveillance video shows several men
inside a plant on the night two
compounds were raided and trashed in
october
200 commercial fishers stopped workers
from leaving one facility
they vandalized the building and dumped
crates full of lobster
days later an enormous fire destroyed
one of the two compounds
the civican akadi first nation has ended
talks with the department of fisheries
and oceans
over its treaty rights in an open letter
to federal fisheries minister bernadette
jordan
chief mike sachs said he understood that
the dfo had been directed by the prime
minister
to ensure our treaty rights were
recognized respected
and exercised safely and without
hindrance however we were sadly
disappointed
21 years ago a supreme court ruling
upheld indigenous fishers rights to earn
a so-called moderate livelihood
outside of regular seasons but
commercial fishers insist
all harvesters should be subject to the
same seasonal rules
it's been eight months since a gunman
disguised as an rcmp officer
killed 22 people in nova scotia the
13-hour rampage is one of the worst mass
killing sprees in canadian history
it began in the tiny village of portopig
where some
traumatized locals are packing up and
moving on
ross lord reports for many people in
porter pick
even the healing power of nature falls
short
not enough to ease their trauma eight
months after the mass killing that left
22 dead 13 people in this village
so there's a structure fire there's a
person down there with a gun uh they're
still looking for him
porter pick is dotted with for sale
signs leon jodry has not slept in his
house
since that horrific night in april jodry
has decided to leave
hoping that will finally bring him peace
i can't sleep here
can't shut my eyes so it's my choice not
to stay here
i'm selling mine i can't speak for
anybody else i'm selling mine for the
images i got in my head of driving
around that night i drive here and
that's all i see among the many
unanswered questions is how the gunman
escaped from port-au-pick to continue
the massacre
despite police claims there were more
than two dozen officers on the scene
very quickly the shooter used an rcmp
disguise
and a fully marked rcmp vehicle to kill
nine more people the next day
before he was gunned down in a chance
encounter with an rcmp officer
the mounties say it's likely he used
this dirt road which was unattended
to get past police and connect with the
highway which they left open
nova scotia's grief coordinator serena
lewis lives near puerto pick
she says grief counseling is already
under resourced in the province
and it's even harder during the pandemic
when physical contact is discouraged
we can't go back to before april 18th
that that doesn't exist anymore
so we will shape a new identity some
people globally have told me this could
be a 20-year span for these communities
that's if we lean in a public inquiry
established by the federal and nova
scotia governments
is due to file a final report on the
massacre in november of 2022
ross lord global news porter pick nova
scotia
and tomorrow ross has a detailed look at
the killer's movements
and more on how that dirt road was used
to evade police
you can see that on the new reality with
donna friesen tomorrow right here on
global
the great 1 million up next aware
collectible scores
a record you may want to think about
those boxes in your parents basement in
case there's a gold mine
in nostalgia trading cards are back and
sending collectors of sports memorabilia
into a spin because there's more than a
pretty penny to be made
as mike delay reports for the first time
a hockey card sold
for over a million dollars you kind of
have to
bend the card around make sure one day
years ago someone thought this was a
good idea
and we all followed along
granted we were kids and had no
foresight this would happen
it's at 300 000 right now that is
already the record
the final price for that wayne gretzky
rookie card 1.2
million dollars u.s and let it be known
i had
had a slew of gretzky cards
until this my mom gave away
all my hockey cards the old friend
who had that that's the story
that's that's why cards like
became valuable 40 years ago because my
mother threw out my hockey cards like
that that famous story
the 13 year old hirsch bornstein
recognized there was money to be made
so he went to his local card store and
was told they'd buy gretzky rookie cards
for a dollar
so i went back to the schoolyard the
next day and said to everyone hey
i'll pay you 50 cents for rookies and 25
cents for second year cards
and i got 13 or 14 cards and i went back
to the store
and i sold them to them he doubled his
money and is now kicking himself like
the rest of us
the card game has certainly changed
nelson galvao buys and opens boxes of
hockey cards online
others do the same with pokemon
oh my gosh and look there's an uncle
jesse card from the tv show full house
and my personal favorite the dick cheney
desert storm card
which nelson was unsure of would you
trade your nathan mckinnon card for that
my nathan mckinnon rookie card
i would hold on to my nathan mckinnon
rookie card
speaking of holding on this spring he
went out on a limb and paid two thousand
dollars for a six out of ten quality
gretzky rookie card
it's now worth six thousand so what do
you do
do you hold on to it or do you triple
your money that's kind of where i'm at
right now i'm like should i
sell it and take that profit right now
since it's kind of like
it's hot right now especially with that
gretzky that just saw
there is a right answer it's not put the
cards in the spoke of your bike
mike dralet global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm robin gill
we leave you with a silent night in a
holy city
[Music]
all is bright in saint peter's square
the vatican has illuminated its annual
christmas tree and nativity scene
the tradition prevailed during the
pandemic a shining symbol of hope
in dark times the 30 meter tall spruce
will glow for 30 days
so more visitors can take in the site
safely
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow good night